Knowledge is power! The more you know,
the better informed your decision can be.
Libraries in that respect play an
incredibly important role in our democracy.
The New York Public Library for instance has an amazing collection of Arctic materials.
Materials about explorers who went to the Arctic;
lost their lives there.
An extraordinary collection of maps of the Arctic
- some accurate, some inaccurate.
And I think
libraries in that way bringing together
researchers, scientists, artists,
sociologists, psychologists, people from
all walks of life can have a very
important role in better understanding
the kind of predicament we find
ourselves in today.
With everything that's going on in the world today with
various political struggles we might
encounter having to do with climate
change or climate control, with people
denying the fact that the world maybe is
warming up,
libraries can in some way be the spokesperson. As an institution they nearly can become the place, the hub,
the place where people congregate around
ideas and learn what the data is,
learn what the challenges are and make better and informed decisions of how the world is
changing and make those decisions based
on a better acquaintance with what the
knowledge of the past is and how the
past will inform the future